Stichwort Autismus.
Greta Thunberg und Asperger
kommen mir spontan in den Sinn,
oder Menschen,
die Telefonbücher auswendig kennen.
Singst du vor dich hin, Kai?
(Mit Lucien und Kai sind wir unter-
wegs nach Urdorf in ihre Schule.)
Kai, alles ist gut. Alles ist gut.
Es kann schlimm sein.
- Wie? Singen? Schreien?
Schreien. Schreien, ja.
Deshalb der Gehörschutz?
Genau. Es gibt Kinder,
die den Pamir ganztags tragen.
Wirklich?
- Ja.
Ihnen ist es wohler damit,
weil unsere Umwelt viel zu laut ist.
Es ist ihnen viel wohler
mit dem Pamir auf.
(Karin sagt, diese Kinder besässen
eine ausgeprägte Form von Autismus.)
(Was das bedeutet,
kann ich noch nicht einschätzen.)
Wenn ich sie grüsse,
kommt keine Reaktion.
Ich weiss nicht, wie ich
mit ihnen Kontakt aufnehmen kann.
Das könnte also
noch schwierig werden.
Hallo, du.
- Hallo.
Wir brauchen noch deinen Rucksack.
Mona Vetsch - drei Tage
bei Kindern mit Autismus.
Auf nichts vorbereitet,
aber auf alles gefasst:
Das ist "Mona mittendrin".
(Das ist Leo, er ist neun.
Und er spricht nicht.)
Jetzt ziehen wir
den Klettergurt aus.
Wofür trägt er ihn?
Weil er im Bus
die Sicherheitsgurte ablegt.
Gut, sehr gut.
Deshalb trägst du deinen
Klettergurt. Eine gute Idee.
Guten Morgen miteinander.
(Alle durcheinander)
Hallo. Guten Morgen.
Was für eine tolle Begrüssung. Mona.
Hallo, Jutta.
- Freut mich, Jutta.
Hallo. Ich bin jetzt ...
Ich bin Alexander.
Gehst du hier zur Schule?
- Mhm.
Gehst du gern zur Schule?
- Ja.- Super.
Wie alt bist du?
- Acht Jahre.
Du darfst deine Sachen aufräumen.
Na klar,
aber jetzt muss ich zu Bastian.
Was für Kinder sind das?
Also in unserer Klasse
befinden sich Kinder,
bei denen die Entwicklungsspanne
sehr breit auseinandergeht.
Kinder, die sprechen, aber auch
Kinder, die nicht sprechen.
Und bei uns ist es sehr wichtig,
dass eigentlich
wenig Sprache stattfindet,
Ich sollte also nicht reden,
nicht fragen:
Wie alt bist du? Woher kommst du?
Entschuldigung.
Bei ihm ist es nicht so extrem,
aber es gibt immer auch Kinder,
bei denen es
herausfordernd werden kann.
Für unsere Kinder ist
eine klare Struktur sehr wichtig.
Ja, okay.
* Glocke *
Zum Plan!
Juchu!
- Juchu!
(Morgenrituale bringen Sicherheit.)
(Jutta sagt,
alles, was neu und anders sei,
sei für Kinder mit Autismus
verwirrend und herausfordernd.)
(Darum würden hier auch
keine Masken getragen,
und ich und mein Kamerateam wurden
bereits letzte Woche angekündigt.)
Den Korb hat der Leo.
Leo.
(Und doch bin ich unsicher,
wie ich mich in diesen drei Tagen
verhalten soll.)
(Soll ich mit den Kindern
Kontakt aufnehmen, oder eben nicht?)
(Und falls ja,
wie tut man das überhaupt?
Achmed.
Alexander.
Danke. Und der ...
Alexander. Der Korb ...
- Der Korb ist leer.
* Lernlied "Das Lied über mich"
von Volker Rosin *
# Ich hab Hände sogar zwei
und auch Haare mehr als drei.
# Ich hab einen runden Bauch
und ne Nase hab ich auch.
# Ich hab links und rechts ein Bein
und ein Herz, doch nicht aus Stein.
# Und jetzt winke ich dir zu,
hallo, du, du, du.
# La la la, la la la, la la la.
(Nebst dem Zusammensein
in der Gruppe,
wird mit jedem Kind
auch allein gearbeitet.)
* Alexander schreit, Mona lacht. *
Wir werden lautstark angekündigt.
Vielen Dank, Alexander,
du hast das super gemacht.
Ich bin Mona.
- Ich bin Patrizia.- Freut mich.
(Lucien ist sieben.)
(Er bäckt einen Kuchen
nach einem genauen Plan
aus Bildern und einzelnen Wörtern.)
Bei ihm gibt es bereits
etwas mehr Schrift als Bilder.
Bei anderen Kindern hat es
noch mehr Bilder als bei ihm,
weil er schon etwas lesen kann.
Das hilft ihm, die Aufgabe
möglichst selbstständig zu lösen.
Ich muss ihm dabei
gar nicht mehr so viel helfen.
Ich finde es unglaublich spannend,
wie komplett unterschiedlich die
Kinder sind, die ich gesehen habe.
Und alles wird Autismus genannt.
Ja, es ist ein breites Spektrum.
Man nennt es heutzutage Spektrum.
Jeder Schüler, den ich bekomme,
ist komplett anders,
stellt mich
vor andere Herausforderungen.
Und das ist auch
das Spannende daran.
Mit jedem neuen Schüler
lerne ich Neues hinzu.
Super. Schau mal.
Kaputt.
- Kaputt.
- Ja, kaputt.
Du kannst es hier hineinwerfen.
Super, super.
Das hast du super gemacht, genau:
Das Ei ist kaputt.
Supi!
(Dass er zusammen mit mir den Kuchen
belegt, und so Kontakt aufnimmt,
sei für Lucien ein grosser Schritt,
sagt Patrizia.)
Ofen?
Ah, jetzt kommt er in den Ofen.
(Ein Schritt aus seiner Welt -
in meine.)
Vorsichtig, heiss.
Hast du dich verbrannt?
- Nein, ist alles gut.
Und fertig!
Fertig.
Und weg.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Das ist der Leo, genau.
(Nach der Schule
besteigen wir wieder den Bus.)
(Ich darf Leo begleiten, denn
seine Familie hat mich eingeladen.)
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Jetzt geht es heimwärts.
Er merkt es.
Ja, er merkt es.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
(Leos Mutter erwartet uns schon.)
(Sonja ist alleinerziehend
und arbeitet bei einer Bank.)
(Nanny Paula
hilft bei der Betreuung.)
(Auch Leos Schwester Valentina
unterstützt sie dabei.)
(Immer wenn Leo
von der Schule zurückkehrt,
will er schnurstracks in den Pool
oder unter die Dusche -
manchmal mitsamt Kleidern.)
Das war es.
Für die nächsten 2 Std.
ist er beschäftigt.- Wirklich?
Ist es einfach für dich,
zu spüren, wie es ihm geht?
Ich denke, obwohl er nicht spricht,
kann er sich sehr gut ausdrücken.
Ich merke sofort,
wenn es ihm nicht gut geht.
Entweder weint er dann
oder er schlägt seinen Kopf
an die Wand oder an die Glasscheibe.
Wenn er etwas will,
holt er mich und zieht mich am Arm
bis zum Objekt oder zur Sache,
das oder die er genau braucht.
Wenn ich das nicht verstehe,
dann ...
Ich muss kurz nachschauen,
weil er den Kopf unter Wasser hält.
Ich muss etwas näher rangehen,
Entschuldigung.
Er hält den Kopf lange unter Wasser.
Wir mussten auch lernen, ihm
zuzutrauen, dass er das schafft.
Das macht ihm auch Spass.
Würden wir ihn
ständig beaufsichtigen,
bedeutete das für uns mehr Stress
und für ihn wäre es ein Zeichen,
dass wir ihm das nicht zutrauten.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Wie habt ihr gemerkt,
dass er an einer Störung leidet?
Er hat schon immer
meinen Augenkontakt vermieden,
sogar schon als Baby, als Säugling.
Und das fand ich
ziemlich merkwürdig.
Nach und nach
haben wir festgestellt,
dass er die Entwicklungsschritte,
also auf der Skala, wie sich Kinder
mit zunehmendem Alter entwickeln,
nicht seinem Alter entsprechend
erreicht.
Dadurch hatten wir
einen Beweis dafür,
dass etwas mit ihm nicht stimmt,
obwohl ich das
schon vorher gemerkt hatte.
Wie war das für dich?
Dein Baby - und man sagt dir ...
Gut, im ersten Moment war es Horror.
Das muss ich jetzt
in keiner Weise beschönigen.
Für jede Mutter, für alle Eltern,
ist es ein Horror,
so etwas zu hören bekommen.
Handkehrum gibt es zwei Wege:
Entweder bricht man zusammen,
eine gewisse Zeit lang
kann man sich das erlauben,
aber irgendwann
muss man wieder aufstehen,
um für die Kinder zu sorgen -
und es sind nun einmal meine Kinder.
Wenn die Eltern nicht dafür kämpfen,
wer sonst?
Das ist unsere Aufgabe.
Und wie ist das Leben
mit einem Kind wie Leo?
Es ist ganz sicher anders,
als man es sich vorstellen kann,
als ich es mir selbst
hätte vorstellen können.
Es ist oft sehr anstrengend.
Aber es ist auch sehr bereichernd,
weil dadurch plötzlich vieles
auf den Kopf gestellt wird.
Unser Tagesplan wird
täglich von Leonardo vorgegeben.
D.h., wenn wir z.B. planen,
morgen wandern zu gehen,
alle Vorbereitungen treffen
und losmarschieren wollen,
aber er will plötzlich nicht raus,
dann wird es keine Wanderung geben.
Dann können wir ein Picknick
im Wohnzimmer veranstalten.
Wenn er Lust verspürt,
schwimmen zu gehen,
dann gehen wir eben alle schwimmen,
weil er alles tun wird,
damit wir mit ihm ins Wasser kommen.
Selbst wenn wir im Winter
am See entlang spazieren,
und er ins Wasser will,
dann geht er ins Wasser.
So lange er klein war,
konnte man ihn gut halten.
Aber jetzt wird er grösser und
stärker - und v.a. sehr schnell.
Aha.
Das klingt jetzt lustig,
aber es gibt bestimmt
auch weniger lustige Situationen.
Es ist manchmal
nicht besonders lustig,
aber wenn man es
auf die leichte Schulter nimmt,
kann es auch schön sein, auch wenn
das nichts an der Situation ändert.
Aber es ist eben
eine Frage der Betrachtungsweise.
Mittlerweile nehmen wir es
ziemlich locker.
* Popmusik aus Radio *
(In der Schweiz
ist ca. eines von 100 Kindern
in irgendeiner Form
von Autismus betroffen.)
(Zwei Drittel davon sind Knaben.)
(Seine Schwester Valentina
hat sogar ein Buch geschrieben
über das Leben
mit ihrem Bruder Leo:
"Der Delfin in der Hängematte".)
Wie ist es für dich, denn Leonardo
ist doch ein spezieller Bruder?
Für mich ist er etwas speziell,
aber irgendwie auch normal.
Wir sind ganz normale Geschwister.
Manchmal haben wir Streit, manchmal
verbringen wir eine gute Zeit.
Manchmal spielen wir auch zusammen.
Für mich ist Leo normal.
Wie ist es denn, wenn du Schul-
kolleginnen mit nach Hause bringst?
Was sagst du ihnen,
wie sie mit Leo umgehen sollen?
Ich sage meistens,
dass er nicht sprechen kann,
kein gutes Gleichgewichtsgefühl hat
und wie ein Schwein isst.
Okay.
Aber manchmal
schauen meine Schulkolleginnen
meinen Bruder bloss sehr seltsam an
und denken, dass er ...
Das fühlt sich dann
nicht sehr angenehm an.
Ich mag es nicht, wenn sie
ihn anglotzen und denken ...
Sie ziehen dann ein seltsames
Gesicht, als würden sie sagen:
"Bäh, das mag ich nicht so."
Das tut mir immer weh.
Was denkst du, ist es für ihn
schlimm, dass er so ist, wie er ist?
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl,
dass er es nicht so toll findet.
Er versucht, uns etwas zu sagen,
aber wir verstehen es nicht.
Dann beginnt er, zu weinen oder
seinen Kopf an die Wand zu schlagen,
weil er wahrscheinlich
das Gefühl bekommt,
nichts sagen,
nichts ausrichten zu können.
In solchen Momenten fühlt er sich
wahrscheinlich ausgeschlossen.
Schau, damit geht es.
Noch mehr?
Willst du noch mehr?
Aha, was willst du?
Nein.
Bist du müde?
Willst du schlafen gehen?
Komm.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Guten Morgen.
(Die Stiftung Kind und Autismus
ist die einzige
Deutschschweizer Institution,
die ausschliesslich
Kinder mit Autismus betreut.)
(Platz hat es für 40 Kinder, aber
die Nachfrage sei viel grösser.)
(Die Bedürfnisse autistischer Kinder
sind speziell.)
(Viele brauchen 1:1-Betreuung.)
(Finanziert wird dieses Angebot
durch Schulgemeinden,
Kantone und Spenden.)
(Ich begleite Kai in die Logopädie.)
(Er hat am Anfang im Bus gesungen.)
(Er ist elf und kommuniziert
mittels eines Sprachcomputers.)
(Computer) Ich möchte Gitarre.
- Ja, die holen wir sofort hervor.
In der Logopädie
liebt er die Gitarre.
In jeder Logopädie-Stunde
wählt er die Gitarre.
Und es ist auch so, dass er ...
Ich möchte Gitarre.
- Okay, ich erzähl es dir nachher.
* Sanfte Melodie *
Ich erstelle einen Ablaufplan,
damit er weiss, was folgt.
Schau, jetzt arbeiten wir.
Willst du nachher Potatohead machen?
Wir setzen ihn etwas höher.
Schau mal.
Damit beginnen wir.
Und damit es du jetzt schon weisst:
Nach der Logopädie-Stunde
wird dich deine Mama abholen.
Schau mal: Fuss.
Mund.
Das oberste Ziel ist,
dass sie ihre Bedürfnisse
mitteilen können.
Damit sie selbstbestimmt
sagen können, was sie wollen.
Wie die Gitarre?
- Genau, und zwar auch in dem Fall,
wenn die Gitarre nicht im Raum steht
und man darauf zeigen kann.
Dass er im Schulzimmer oben sagen
kann, dass er die Gitarre will.
Von der Wahrnehmung her
kann man sich vorstellen,
dass Menschen mit Autismus
keinen Filter besitzen.
Viele Geschehnisse
nehmen sie gleichzeitig wahr.
Sie können nichts herausfiltern.
Wenn wir z.B. miteinander sprechen,
hören wir Kai zwar,
aber wir können ihn
auch etwas ausblenden.
Unter Umständen kann es sein,
dass Kai alles
gleich laut wahrnimmt.
Es kann auch sein,
dass Menschen mit Autismus
Geräusche nicht von gesprochenen
Worten unterscheiden können.
Hören sie dann einen Brei?
- Genau.
Das beeinträchtigt den Spracherwerb
massiv.
Hast du etwas Weiches gefunden?
Kai hat bei Dominik
das Mikrofon entdeckt.
Es fühlt sich toll an,
es ist sehr weich.
Streich mal drüber. Fühlt sich
wie eine Katze an, nicht?
* Klopfen *
Hallo. Hallo, Grosser.
Hallo, Schatz.
Hallo, Frau Auernig.
Hallo, ich bin Nicole.
- Ich bin Mona Vetsch.
Freut mich.
Ich bin die Mutter von Kai.
Freut mich sehr. Schön, dich
kennenzulernen.- Danke gleichfalls.
Ich habe etwas über den Spracherwerb
von autistischen Kindern gelernt.
Wie kommunizierst du mit Kai?
Wie redet ihr miteinander?
Auf viele verschiedene Arten.
Mittlerweile verstehen wir einander
ziemlich gut - fast immer.
Nicht immer, aber fast immer.
* Kai schreit. *
Wenn er das
mitten auf der Strasse tun würde,
wäre das nicht so toll, würden
die Leute sofort genervt reagieren:
"Geht's eigentlich noch?"
sagen Passanten normalerweise.
Und was antwortest du?
Normalerweise sage ich,
er sei behindert.
Wenn es gut geht,
reagieren sie anständig.
Aber manchmal laufen sie auch davon
und schütteln den Kopf.
Das tut mir immer weh, weil er
schon genug durchmachen muss.
Das braucht es nicht auch noch,
etwas Empathie wäre wünschenswert.
Aber wir arbeiten daran,
dass er nicht so laut ist,
aber es braucht noch etwas Zeit.
Es ist nicht so einfach.
(Es geht darum, Kindern wie Kai
Werkzeuge mitzugeben,
mit denen sie in unserer Welt der
sog. Neurotypischen zurechtkommen.)
Ich will Joghurt.
- Okay.
Warte kurz hier, Mami holt Joghurt.
Ihr sprecht
über den Computer miteinander.
Wenn mir nicht ganz klar ist,
wo das Problem liegt,
frage ich nach, ob er etwas möchte,
dann erhalte ich so Antwort.
Hast du noch nichts gegessen?
Muss ich es für dich öffnen? Hier.
Aber nicht in den Pool damit,
sonst klebt es in den Haaren.
Setz dich dort drüben hin.
Sehr gut.
Seit wann funktioniert das
mit dem Sprachcomputer?
An der Methode mit dem Bildstreifen
zeigte er wenig Interesse.
Weil er sehr oft
mit dem iPad gespielt hat,
probierten wir es
mit dem Sprachcomputer aus.
Wir haben gemerkt, dass ihm dieser
gut gefällt. Das fand er super.
* Kai schreit. *
Kai muss sich eben ...
etwas erholen.
Die Leute von der Schule
fanden das auch gut.
Seit zwei Jahren arbeiten wir damit.
Nächstes Jahr erhält er
einen neuen Sprachcomputer.
Kai, Schatz, was machst du?
Käse? Also, geh raus.
Dieser Sprachcomputer
ist nicht optimal.
Z.B. hat es auf dieser Tastatur
keinen Knopf für Käse.
Weil er jetzt lieber Käse
anstelle von Joghurt wollte,
konnte er das nicht sagen
und ging es deshalb selbst holen.
Wie fühlt es sich an,
Mutter eines Kindes zu sein,
das an Autismus leidet?
Es ist z.T. herausfordernd.
Im Alltag kennt er keine Gefahren.
Wir können ihn
nicht einfach allein spielen lassen.
Er würde einfach auf die Strasse
vor ein Auto rennen.
Er kann nicht nachvollziehen,
dass ein Auto ihn überfahren kann.
Was?
Entschuldigung.
Ich weiss, was du willst.
Sag es! Ja, zeig, zeig, zeig!
Sag: U
- U.
F. U.
U.
- Okay.
Auf. Er mag es,
wenn ich meine Haare offen trage.
Gut.
- Aha, auf.
Genau, wir trainieren.
Aber bitte, Schatz,
erst isst du bitte fertig.
Dann kannst du
wieder schwimmen gehen.
Er mag einfach Frauen
mit langen Haaren.
Er würde ihnen
gerne in die Haare greifen.
Ja, er mag einfach lange Haare.
Wenn du in die Zukunft schaust ...
Jetzt geht er noch zur Schule,
wohnt noch zu Hause,
aber wie wird das
für ihn einmal werden?
Ich weiss es nicht, Mona.
Wir denken oft darüber nach.
Es bereitet uns Angst.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Deswegen ist es
für uns sehr wichtig,
dass er so selbstständig
wie möglich wird,
dass er so gut wie möglich
zu kommunizieren lernt.
Ich werde nicht aufgeben,
ihm das Alphabet beizubringen,
ihn die Namen der Körperteile
zu lehren.
Irgendwann wird er
auf sich selbst gestellt sein,
denn ich werde nicht ewig leben.
Er muss selbst ausdrücken können,
wenn er irgendwo Schmerzen hat.
Auf die Toilette gehen,
das kann er schon,
aber Kai kann nicht sagen, wenn ihm
etwas weh tut. Das geht nicht.
Deshalb finde ich das sehr wichtig.
Es macht Angst. Ich weiss nicht,
wie es wird. Das werden wir sehen.
(Das grosse Ziel ist
das Selbständigerwerden.)
(Ein- bis zweimal pro Woche
übernachten die Kinder deshalb
in der Institution.)
Die Kinder schlafen
meistens entweder alleine,
zu zweit oder zu dritt.
Wovon ist das abhängig?
Je nachdem, wie gut sie
während der Nacht schlafen.
Manche bleiben auch häufig wach
oder haben während der Nacht
viele Wachzeiten.
Weil andere Kinder
nicht deswegen erwachen sollen,
schlafen solche Kinder alleine.
Und so sehen die Zimmer aus.
Genau, sehr neutral.
Das ist auch
sehr neutral ausgedrückt.
Mich erinnert es ...
- Sehr reizarm.
Reizarm, aha.
Es besitzt den Charme dieser Lager,
in denen wir als Pfadfinder ...
Weisst du ...
Aber das ist Absicht, nehme ich an.
Ja, das ist Absicht.
Teilweise hatten wir auch schon
Bilder an den Wänden,
aber es hängt von den Kindern ab,
ob das möglich ist.
Damit nichts vorhanden ist,
das die Kinder aufwühlen
oder ablenken könnte
(Ich übernachte heute hier.)
Danke, Achmed.
Mein Zimmer.
Schön, du.
* Fröhliche Musik aus Radio. *
Ich glaube, das ist Leo.
Leo hat sich bereits zurückgezogen.
Ja.
Er geht selbst zu Bett.
Ist das okay für euch?
- Ja.
Sie sollen sich ruhig
eine Rückzugsmöglichkeit suchen,
wo sie sich erholen
und entspannen können.
Wie war es bei ihm? Hat er
von Anfang an hier gut geschlafen?
Ja.
* Fröhliche Musik aus dem Radio. *
* Französisches Chanson
mit Handorgelbegleitung *
* Soundtrack von Yann Tiersen zu "Le
Fabuleux Destin d'Amélie Poulain" *
* Kinderlied "Luege, was dä Mond
so macht" von Linard Bardill *
* Spannende Jazzklänge *
(Es war eine ruhige Nacht - fast.)
Morgen.
Mein kleiner Zimmernachbar
gebärdete sich heute Morgen
um etwa 5 Uhr wie eine Sirene.
Und dann öffnete sich
meine Zimmertüre etwas
und ein kleines Köpfchen
erschien im Türspalt.
Er wollte wohl nachsehen, ...
Wir haben uns
schon frühmorgens getroffen.
Er wollte wohl nachsehen,
ob ich auch schon wach bin.
Das war niedlich.
War es Achmed? Oder etwa
doch sein Zwillingsbruder?
Ich bin nicht sicher.
(Jedes Kind lebt
in seinem eigenen Kosmos.)
(Für die Betreuenden heisst das,
kreativ sein.)
(Und Antworten finden auf Fragen,
die sie manchmal
nur erahnen können.)
* Unverständliche Worte *
Magst du dir was nachschenken?
Du darfst noch mal nachschenken.
Geht das so?
Langsam, Andro.
Pause.
Du kannst die Sanduhr umdrehen.
Andro kann gut regulieren,
wenn er eine Sanduhr hat.
So trinkt er
nicht das ganze Glas aus.
Wirklich?
- Ja.
Wenn ein Glas voll ist,
ist es oft so,
dass es ganz geleert werden muss.
Zwanghaft.
- Wirklich?- Ja.
Es wird nicht langsam
in einzelnen Schlucken getrunken,
sondern das Glas wird
in einem Zug leergetrunken.
Damit es erledigt ist.
- Alles muss geleert werden.
Die natürliche Regulation
fehlt also?
Ja, bei vielen.
(Und dann stehe ich plötzlich
als Hundesitterin im Einsatz.)
(Die Eltern von Lucien
sind auf Besuch.)
(Wir unternehmen einen Spaziergang.)
Hallo, Lucien.
Warten.
Für Aussenstehende
ist es schwierig einzuordnen,
wenn wir unserem Kind Hundekommandos
geben wie "Stopp" oder "Warten".
Wenn ich sage: "Lucien, bitte
warte beim nächsten Baum auf uns",
sind das zu viele Informationen,
die er nicht verarbeiten kann.
Wenn ich will, dass er stehenbleibt,
muss ich "Stopp" sagen.
Das nimmt er sofort auf.
(Ein Kind wie Lucien zu haben,
sei ein Abenteuer.)
Man weiss nicht, was passiert - auch
wenn wir einen Spielplatz besuchen.
Lucien liebt Spielplätze über alles.
Er rennt sofort hin,
das ist auch super.
Manchmal versucht er auf seine Art,
mit anderen Kindern
Kontakt aufzunehmen,
was die anderen Kinder
wiederum nicht verstehen -
und manchmal gar nicht.
Mit anderen Kindern
kann es natürlich auch immer
zu seltsamen Situationen kommen.
Die anderen Kindern
können ihn auch nicht einschätzen
und reagieren dementsprechend -
vielfach ablehnend.
Wie ist das für dich als Vater,
wenn du das siehst?
Dann bin ich jeweils etwas hilflos
und weiss auch nicht,
was ich tun soll.
(Lucien konnte sich anfangs nicht
mal seinen Eltern mitteilen.)
Ups!
* Lucien weint. *
(Inzwischen hat er gelernt,
mit Menschen Kontakt aufzunehmen.)
(Aber in solchen Situationen
ist er am liebsten allein.)
* Lucien weint schreiend. *
Trösten klappt nicht?
Nein, das geht gar nicht.
- Warum nicht?
Ich vermute, dass es in diesem
Moment zu viele Reize gibt.
Er ist völlig
mit dem Schmerz beschäftigt.
Wenn wir dann noch kommen,
wird es zu viel.
Aua. Viel. Viel.
Viel? Viel Au?
Als Mutter musstest du lernen,
ihn nicht instinktiv zu umarmen,
sondern ihm den Raum zu überlassen.
- Genau, das war wirklich hart.
Hart für dich?
- Mhm.
Von aussen sieht es aus,
als wäre ich eine Rabenmutter.
Der Knabe weint, ist verletzt,
und sie kümmert sich nicht um ihn.
Denn wenn du ihn halten willst ...
- ... ist es völlig vorbei.
* Beschwingte Klavierklänge *
(Über die Ursachen von Autismus
weiss man noch wenig.)
(Die Genetik spiele eine Rolle,
heisst es.)
(Was genau im Bewusstsein
autistischer Kinder vorgeht,
wie bei Lucien, Leo oder Kai,
und wie ihre Welt aussieht,
bleibt für uns zu einem grossen Teil
im Verborgenen.)
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Hallo.
- Sonja.- Hallo.
Wenn du einen Wunsch frei hättest,
was würdest du dir für Leo
und Kinder wie ihn wünschen?
Ich wünsche mir, dass er so schnell
wie möglich selbstständig wird,
dass er seinen Weg gehen
und sich ausdrücken kann,
auch wenn es nicht verbal ist.
Dass er sich ausdrücken
und so viel lernen kann wie möglich,
damit er selbstständig wird.
Ja.
- Und damit er auch verstanden wird.
Mit meinem Daumen
wirst du nicht glücklich.
Leider kenne ich
deinen PIN-Code nicht,
aber ich halte es für dich.
(Man muss
nicht immer alles verstehen,
um Verständnis
entwickeln zu können.)
(Und das brauchen Lucien,
Kai und Leo und ihre Familien
von uns als Gesellschaft
als Unterstützung auf ihrem Weg,
der nicht einfach ist.)
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Roger Schmid - 2021